[Musique]
et c'est l'heure de passer à notre
chronique sur les animaux c'est avec
vous à Tiz barré alors ce soir vous
allez nous parler des frelons asiatiques
c'est devenu un véritable fléau pour nos
apiculteurs exactement Mathilde donc ce
soir on va parler du frelon asiatique
pour protéger en fait nos abeilles en
fait les frelons asiatiques sont devenus
un véritable danger pour les hommes mais
également pour les insectes puisque les
frelons asiatiques consomment énormément
d'insectes et ils vont également manger
des abeilles donc le but ce soir est de
donner des gestes simples pour protéger
les abeilles puisque la menace est
double le frelon asiatique donc là on
est sur la période où il va sortir de
l'hibernation au mois d'août une fois
que son lit sera complètement construit
il va être difficile de lutter contre le
frelon asiatique qui se nourrit en fait
un nid se nourrit de 1 kg d'insectes
donc c'est énorme donc c'est un danger
pour la biodiversité également donc pour
les abeilles puisque les abeilles vont
être attendus à la sortie des ruches par
les frelons asiatiques qui vont aller
les attaquer pour aller les manger on
dirait que je parle d'un film d'horreur
mais c'est la réalité donc voilà et puis
du coup les butineuses bon bah elle va
elles vont avoir peur de sortir et donc
bah les le miel va se faire de plus en
plus rare alors comment différencier le
frelon asiatique du frelon européen
alors ça c'est une bonne question parce
que c'est difficile de faire la
différence entre les deux et c'est très
important pour protéger nos ruches alors
le frelon asiatique il est plus petit il
mesure 3 cm il a une tête qui est orange
avec un anneau orange au niveau du
thorax il pilule plus vite et il mange
beaucoup plus que le frelon européen
pilule ça veut dire qu'il bat des ailes
plus vite non ça veut dire qu'ils font
qui va pondre faire des naissances plus
plus rapidement et au niveau du frelon
européen donc lui il est un peu plus
grand il mesure 4 cm il est brun il a
donc un thorax avec un anneau orange et
des pâtes brunes au niveau également de
l'Habitat vous pouvez faire la
différence avec le nid du frelon
asiatique il a des écailles celui du
frelon européen c'est un forme d'icône
l'entrée du nid du frelois asiatique
elle est plus petite et elle est exposée
en lumière et celui du frelon européen
lui plus dans les greniers au niveau des
endroits sombres et j'ai même étudié
donc leur comportement leur psychologie
le frelon asiatique lui donc il va être
il va être plus féroce il va attaquer
plus rapidement que le four européen
n'est plus pacifique il va attaquer
uniquement en cas de danger alors vous
le disiez juste à l'instant c'est c'est
un vrai un véritable fléau pour nos
apiculteurs c'est un problème pour eux
oui tout à fait donc si les apiculteurs
qui tirent la sonnette d'alarme j'ai
monsieur Delmotte c'est un apiculteur de
carrière sous Poissy qui est venu me
voir sur Poissy actuellement au ski il
m'a prêté sa tenue donc il m'a donc
donné également c'est ses pièges pour
nous initier à des gestes très simples
avec quelques gestes on peut sauver les
abeilles donc là vous avez par exemple
un piège ou le l'abeille elle pourra
rentrer et sortir alors que le frelon
asiatique lui va être coincé à
l'intérieur ça c'est un piège qui coûte
environ 30 euros sinon on a des méthodes
un peu plus simple vous avez le bouchon
tout ça ça coûte environ 1,50 € ou alors
vous avez la méthode de la bouteille que
vous fabriquez votre piège vous-même
vous coupez donc la bouteille en deux
avec le bouchon on met à l'intérieur du
vin blanc du jus de cassis et donc on va
pallier à cette attaque du frelon
asiatique qui va se retrouver piégé à
l'intérieur et donc si on retrouve un
nid de frelons asiatique près de chez
nous qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire on
utilise ces pièges mais est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres choses à faire on fait appel à
un professionnel surtout on va pas
soi-même s'attaquer au niveau du nid
donc si c'est au niveau de votre rue
donc vous appelez votre mairie elle va
faire appel à un professionnel si c'est
dans votre habitation n'hésitez pas à
contacter votre assureur votre assurance
habitation parce que les pompiers ne se
déplacent plus maintenant pour les nid
de guêpes donc vous allez peut-être des
garanties au niveau de vos garanties
assistantes au niveau de vos contrats
l'intervention sera pris en charge et
alors juste ces pièges où est-ce qu'on
doit les placer alors Lenny en fait il
se forme au niveau de la taille de
l'homme donc vous pouvez les disposer au
niveau des arbres ou alors au sol si
vous avez constaté la présence d'Annie
sur une année auparavant vous placez le
piège à côté puisque les fondatrices
vont revenir après des premiers ni merci
beaucoup à this pour tous vos merci à
vous pour les gestes pour la
biodiversité je suis également venue
avec un petit peu de miel si vous
souhaitez le goûter de notre apiculteur
de l'apiculteur voilà et c'est quoi
comme miel alors celui-là c'est mon
préféré c'est le miel de châtaigne de
châtaignes
on va goûter ça alors miel de châtaigne
il a un petit peu dur
si vous voulez goûter
[Rires]
il est très bon ce miel et ben voilà il
faut continuer à respecter le travail
des apiculteurs
c'est bon pour les sportifs
pour la santé exactement et donc Cathy
sont vos retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour une nouvelle chronique sur les
animaux donc la semaine prochaine pour
une nouvelle chronique je serai en
présence d'un lapin d'un lapin
vous allez nous parler de quoi du coup
je bah c'est l'année du Lapin également
donc je vais vous parler un petit peu de
la psychologie des lapins je vais vous
ramener un lapins qui devait être
abandonné dans une forêt et qui a été
recueillie par une famille psychique